ben shapiro of daley wired.com he's the
editor in chief and host of the ben
shapiro show which i listened to daily
then this broke just about fifty minutes
ago really changed the day the summer
and possibly the court for generations
to come and love your thoughts on it I
mean it's an astonishing astonishing
change I mean Anthony Kennedy has been a
swing vote on a number of major issues
now I would caution the Justice Roberts
has a tendency to try and be that swing
vote from time to time so what we could
see is an evolution of Chief Justice
Roberts toward the center but barring
that this could be the first time in
generations that conservatives have
actually controlled the majority on the
Supreme Court given the fact that
president Trump's list of 25 potential
justices virtually all of them have
long-standing track records as strong
conservatives if the president makes the
right pick here not only is it going to
energize the base for 2018 and presume
and presumably for his reelection run in
2020 but also it could radically change
the nature of the courts move because
the the for hardcore folks on the left
on the court would certainly have moved
the court in a radically different
direction than the current court has
constituted had Justice Kennedy waited
for three years and for a Democratic
president possibly to retire let me read
to you a few of the issues that from the
left that they are telling the Democrats
you know this is what could happen if
President Trump gets to replace Anthony
Kennedy on the court that the court
would be more likely to overturn roe v
wade restrict affirmative action
rollback anti-discrimination law and
protect the death penalty in solitary
confinement just to name a few so on the
left that's what they're concerned about
your thoughts I don't think that's
completely inaccurate I mean the fact is
the Rovi way is a horribly decided
decision now any justice that the
President appoints should be against roe
v wade because anybody who's read the
Constitution should be against roe v
wade even if you are a pro-choice person
now the left is immediately jumping to
the conclusion that even if OVA were
overturned that would mean half the
country outlaws abortion forthwith I
think that is highly unlikely but with
that said what we are looking at is a
possible epical shift in in the in the
nature of the Supreme Court it really is
it could not be bigger and the timing of
it is astonishing for 2018 for him